welcome to vanderpump dogs  [Music]  we created this rescue center and with  our incredible team  we have found homes for more than 2 000  dogs  this is herme mary it's like a dating  process  this is larry you want to have a little  foreplay before you go all the way  this is angel nice it's violet what did  you think  i want three dogs it's a lot of picking  up poop  i'll take one the goal is to make these  dogs feel like vips  lvps vips a vanderpuff entails shampoos  brush out then i go into places your  barber doesn't go  [Music]  this is duke oh my god that looks like  my husband  i'm sure i married you 38 years ago  we have to be sure that this is the best  option for the dog  i feel ready for it  it's not about just finding somebody  attractive  across the bar this isn't a one night  stand this is a life-long relationship  i'm just so happy that he's going to be  my forever dog  i couldn't have asked for anything  [Music]  better  you